all right guys
bang bang i've got yoni here thank you
so much for doing this sir
thank you very much for having me always
a pleasure this is
either your second or third time on the
podcast so i'm not gonna
waste a bunch of time going through the
background people can go listen to the
first
episode uh but spend maybe 30 seconds
on just what is etoro sure
he toro today is the world's largest
social trading network we have over 16
million
registered users who register to our
social network
uh where they can trade commission free
stock trading
cryptocurrencies commodities indices uh
etfs uh in more than a hundred different
countries
uh and the unique part of etoro is you
can actually see
people's performance and their
portfolios and our users can
automatically copy
top traders from all over the world and
invest in
our copy portfolios uh we've been doing
this for a while now founded in 2007
uh uh quite big in europe in
asia and just recently launched uh in
the us
our crypto trading social network to
start with and plan to add soon
our commission free stock trading as
well one of the things that everyone
knows you for is obviously all the
retail trading all the retail products
but you recently put a big focus on
institutional services help us
understand what exactly are you guys
doing on the institutional side and
how's that going so far
sure so basically what we did is we had
a surge in volumes in 2017 and 18 in
crypto so
we had to build a lot of our own pipes
because there weren't any real
institutional
players uh back then so we had to build
our own
aggregator where we connected to
multiple exchanges to 10 different
exchanges
to basically aggregate orders from
multiple exchanges
into our own order book so when our
customers
in some cases came and bought 200
million dollars of bitcoin in one day
we'll be able to basically get these
orders and you know distribute them
between
several exchanges of course there's a
lot of things like
you know what's the credit risk some of
these exchanges or all of them by the
way aren't public right so
i i back then was impossible to trade
with
uh highly regulated uh and sort of
uh large financial institutions in
crypto
so we had to sort of uh diversify the
risk of how we're trading
and we build a lot of the technology
again for us because
we had hundreds of thousands of
customers who came into etoro
to buy xrp ethereum bitcoin
and all the other currencies we support
in etoro
uh and at some point we said okay let's
take all of this infrastructure that
we've built to ourselves
so military grade air gaps custody
solution
uh the fact that we're a regulated
entity the fact that we have
our own flow which is hundreds of
millions of dollars
a day going through our own internal
order books
and simply let's put it out there as a
as a product
and tell other institutions other
brokers uh listen this
this is the infrastructure we're using
for ourselves
um you know the best possible security
because we custody a significant amount
of crypto and etoro uh
it's regulated because we're a regulated
broker-dealer
in five different continents so we make
sure everything
we do uh is regulated as a financial
institution
and obviously we need to give a great
service and great pricing to our own
customers
and you're getting it in a much lower
fee when you trade directly with etoro x
and so far what's been the response and
kind of adoption
of those institutional products so we've
seen a lot of
uh institutions sort of evaluate the
apis
or do the onboarding and some of them
buy and hold so i think
what we so far have seen is institutions
eventually coming to sort of buy and
hold uh thinking about sort of
custody more than anything else
i think what we're seeing now is a
bigger interest we're seeing
more and more partners who are looking
to figure out how do they connect it to
their pipes and again that's what
was what really are thinking when you
look at dbs bank in singapore
or s or the banks in japan so
we built this so when traditional
financial institutions
want to connect into crypto uh
they understand that we can provide them
the same services we provide
to our own regulated entities so there
are a lot of conversations there are a
lot of accounts
but i think they're not they're getting
their institutions are gradually getting
there
to put in the pipes in place i think
that's also what we're seeing
now in this rally that we're seeing in
bitcoin
um i think we're seeing this rally
because
some selected institutions said
okay let's you know let's put a pedal to
the metal
uh let's set up the infrastructure
whether it's paypal
uh or whether it's uh square also
announcing they're buying out of their
treasury or micro
micro strategy buying out of their
treasury
obviously the devaluation of traditional
fiat currencies helps that as well
but i i think our expectation is we'll
see more and more
traditional financial institutions
uh coming in and act and eventually
connecting the pipes
to their either retail or institutional
customers uh and we just want to provide
them with the same back-end that we're
providing ourselves
absolutely and i think this is part of
this larger trend of
you know ten years ago or eight years
ago uh it was all
the conversation around like criminals
drug dealers terrorists that's what
crypto's for
you know these people are all bad people
keep this out of our banks keep this out
of
our uh our portfolios maybe you know
four or five years ago
you started to see people saying wait a
second like what is this let me get
educated
now it feels like there's just this
bonanza of
large asset managers large financial
institutions that are saying i have to
do something here right even the
jpmorgans of the world kind of releasing
um you know all sorts of analyst letters
about uh
their belief in kind of the future uh
price appreciation and kind of the
demographics and things like that
so it just feels like things have gotten
much more legitimate in the eyes of the
legacy market
you've been doing this longer than
almost anybody
literally from like what 2011 2012 how
do you think about where we are in terms
of that arc of legitimacy
and kind of how these financial
institutions now are warming up to this
so i think again first of all i love the
goldman and jp research on bitcoin i
just enjoy seeing their logos of their
research
uh talking about bitcoin um and their
views are getting better as well by the
way i think
the pandemic everybody's talking about
how the pandemic
has accelerated digital transformation
right suddenly everybody's at home
the last time we did this was in person
now we're doing it on zoom
um people are closing deals everything
is online
you know we've seen a surge of 200 300
400 percent
uh in different kpis this year more than
four million
new registered users to etoro you but
you can see the stock markets as well
everything that's digital has become
the hot thing of the markets because
suddenly
everybody's using digital to do anything
whether it's trading or investing
uh or whether you know it's suddenly my
my father uh and mother who were now
suddenly buying constantly on amazon in
aliexpress
uh and traditionally they were actually
going to the stores
so and i think we are seeing the same
acceleration of digital transformation
in money they are looking at this and
saying
okay let's make sure we don't miss this
train because something really is
happening here
take into account that the vps and
managing directors
now at all of the large banks
are our age um so you know millennials
are taking over the executive positions
in the banks the decision-making
positions in banks and financial
institutions
and they're much much more open to
crypto
and on the other hand we have a macro
shift in fiscal policy we have
a stimulus of six trillion dollars in
the u.s
like i i can't count in trillions
anymore uh you know i used to be
uh always i made funded assets under
management in the world or 140 uh
i think it's trillion dollars right so
that's such a big number
but now you're seeing governments print
in trillions europe
asia everywhere now that printing is
basically devaluing fiat currency
and that is a discussion that more and
more people
are talking about i i heard from one of
the bank's
analysts yesterday he said something
very interesting he said listen
you need to have an asset in your
portfolio
that's a real protection from central
bank policy of of money printing
and bitcoin represents that on a macro
view and i think more and more
institutions are getting that
but i think we're way way way way way
early in in in the adoption
of of crypto or specifically of bitcoin
as a store of value love how jp looked
at it and said listen
if if it could be gold it could go 10x
um but again
if you think about i don't know how
would you compare
google before google was google right
you couldn't imagine its
size so i think comparing it to gold
saying its kit can go 10x
then you can also think okay but what if
digital gold is actually
better and bigger than regular gold as a
store of value
yeah i absolutely say all the time like
it is more likely that we are all
underestimating how big this will get
rather than overestimating it right
it's just that when you look at things
on a global basis
uh the power of the internet the number
of people right
already is big and then it's only
getting bigger over time
and when you start to think about an
entire demographic of people basically
waking up and growing up with the idea
that they want digital goods rather than
kind of physical
goods it's just really hard to
kind of compartmentalize those different
trends and understand how big it gets
right so i completely agree there
what have you guys seen people doing uh
during the recent rise whether it's in
the stock market or in crypto like are
there changes in behavior
that are very obvious to you um that you
guys say look you know in our data we're
seeing
x or y happen well
first of all again this year has been
the year
of the rise of the millennial investor
um
everybody's talking about it everybody's
seeing it you know
we're we're seeing if you know when we
saw the crypto rally
it was the crypto rally like we were so
it was like a zombie attack on etoro
you know people climbing over the doors
opening accounts coming to buy bitcoin
then this year it's it's really i think
that
the rally is about an entire generation
waking up to the markets and saying
i want to do something with my money
right so this entire year
everywhere people are talking about
stocks
people are talking about investing in
the markets the markets have been
crazy interesting crypto has been
interesting as well with a very wide
range and now
at the peak since uh uh the you know the
bubble burst
in uh 2017 uh so i think
this really is the year uh that's
opening up the millennial investors uh
to start uh investing
both in the markets and in crypto
because we were so big in europe in
crypto
in 2017 what we saw which is really
interesting
is how many of these bitcoin if
xrp hodlers suddenly started trading
stocks this year
and what stocks did the crypto holders
buy
um and and what's interesting is their
affinity to
uh driverless cars to tesla and to neo
so those are the you know for a large
period this year the most traded stocks
on etoro
uh so you can say that crypto lovers
uh which is sort of rightly like digital
currencies
uh or in digitization um
and maybe blockchain is like a
comparison for drive of scars ai
so there is some connection between the
two but that's very like
interesting to see how bitcoiners
are also teslars um
other than that i think you know we've
just seen
a lot of users look for the deep during
the pandemic
uh by the way the same with crypto so i
think when
we saw march we saw bitcoin
did it drop almost 6 000 right so
in march it went uh just below four
thousand at one point for a second i
think
oh no why didn't i buy
wow really it went that deep uh yeah
that's like
one of the biggest things this year is
to say why did i buy march more stocks
and crypto
so we had that fear when the markets
panicked uh for us it was an
insane month both in crypto and in the
stock so
when all of the institutions and that's
so interesting to see like the
dynamic between you know panic and
hysteria and how
different audiences or how do different
age demographics and institution versus
retail
sort of how do they react to panic and
hysteria right so
there was a panic when i say hysteria in
positive hysteria
like the markets going up this week five
or ten percent
so when we saw the panic in march we saw
i think institutions pulling out money
right so all of the institutions were
de-risking
saying wow there's a condemning here
what are we going to do
put all of the money in cash nobody knew
the size of the stimulus effect and i
think what happened there
is that asset managers that had crypto
still held crypto as a risk asset which
is interesting
because that theory that that we
bitcoiners like to say
that bitcoin is a great hedge to the
portfolio codes
it's uncorrelated asset uh and because
um it's basically de-risking central
bank
printing of money so it's a hedge
against governments
so i think that statement i i truly
believe in it
but that's not necessarily the reason or
the bucket where
a lot of the institutional money went in
i think institutional money initially
went into
crypto not as a treasury hedge but as a
speculative
uh a wager so somebody
young at some of these institutions said
hey
let's do this everybody's talking about
crypto let's be in crypto let's buy 50
million or 100 billion for crypto
and i think when we saw the crunch
coming and
everybody going to panic a lot of people
sold and that's why we saw
crypto drop uh so much
um because it's because they all tried
to
simply de-risk their portfolios and i
think what we're seeing
now suddenly is investors actually
coming in
from that different perspective they're
coming in
as a treasury asset into bitcoin what's
really interesting that we saw this year
and that's crazy and i know we've put a
lot of data out there there was a lot of
data out there
is discount stocks so in march
when everything dropped was the highest
revenues uh month for etoro
uh since the crypto in 2017 where we had
in one month 100 million dollar revenue
so this
was like one month just blown after
promotion of just
retail investors coming in and saying
whoa whoa whoa
why is everybody going out of the market
what really changed work and they bought
everything
like we saw a retail investor buying
hairs
fedex airlines boeing like our top
10 traded stocks back then was stocks
that went down
80 90 and
that was awesome because by the way
recently they all made a lot of money
right because of the rebound um but but
that's also
telling you the story of crypto in the
markets right retail investors can take
by definition
higher levels of risk because it's their
own personal money
they're not managing other people's
money and that's what they did this year
they came into the market
they tried to save companies going
bankrupt
which is an amazing story that i don't
think has ever happened
before and became a significant force
in the markets i think from about 10
percent of volumes in the markets
retail are now 25 percent of volumes in
the markets
so that's a very big shift towards
retail
and i think if you think about crypto
it's the opposite right i think it's 80
90 percent
retail now and gradually we'll see
institutions coming in and taking a
bigger piece of the pipe
yep you've talked a lot about kind of
this millennial investor
and i think that millennial investor and
retail are somewhat
interchangeable but what else have you
seen those millennial investors so you
mentioned you know crypto obviously
uh there's tesla there's what i'll call
a lot of like the pandemic stocks so
whether it's the zooms of the world the
hertz's
you know all those stories that people
have heard was there anything that was
really surprising
uh or anything that maybe people don't
know that the millennial investor
uh was interested in that you guys were
seeing
i i think and that's a part of how we're
building the copy portfolios on etoro
so whatever we're seeing and saying hey
that's interesting we'll actually set up
a portfolio on etoro
so investors can get access to to sort
of that data
so renewable energy was a very big thing
this year
um so we've seen a lot of our clients
going into companies like solaredge
on a proportionate amount of assets in
etoro are going towards
renewable energy uh in sustainable
investing
um so the likes of sort of beyond meat
tesla neo also
are in that category so electric cars
so we definitely saw the audience sort
of looking for disruptive technology
um we saw them uh going into gene
editing
uh which is uh sort of both we created
two copy portfolios around that what is
what is about
around the vaccine companies uh so also
unproportioned you know
drug companies were so boring last year
like if if i would
try to talk to you about pfizer or
moderna
or gilead you would be like uh you know
who are they suddenly we have retail
investors who are analyzing
the financials of pfizer and estimating
how much money
they're going to do from the vaccine for
covet
and what's interesting in these things
is if you think about retail investors
suddenly analyzing and we see this
really interesting like
on on the social network giving a full
analysis of suddenly
drunk drug companies and comparing them
to one another
that's very interesting because that
means retail investors aren't
only exposed to what we've seen so far
which is the fangs
right the fangs and teslas etc suddenly
because of the pandemic
they went into things like drug
companies which is a big category
healthcare health tech
big category of the s p but also into
utilities
into airlines um and into
leasing companies and into uh you know
boeing and airbus airbus was the most
traded stock in germany for like a month
or two earlier this year
uh and that enables more people to
both impact the markets but also
understand what's happening in these
companies
yeah it's really interesting when uh you
also look at
um those things don't seem so risky
to that millennial investor right when
you're talking about gene editing when
you're talking about renewable energy
when you're talking about sustainable
meat
uh i think that most people are like of
course right if you're under a certain
age it's just
of course that's gonna happen um very
similar to i think you know bitcoin
that's why the younger demographic is
just
of course digital goods are gonna be a
thing of course these uh trends are
going to happen
um and so it seems like they are putting
their money where their mouth is to some
degree
right and they're all making money this
year
which is great i mean that's always a
good you know
people coming into the market making
money becomes viral they talk to their
friends about it
more people are coming in they're
learning they're better tools today than
there were
five years ago or 10 years ago they're
communicating
with one another from all over the world
so i i think we are seeing
a you know a real new sort of era for
capital markets uh which is you know
what we've been chiming since 2007
uh is you know open the global markets
for everyone to trade invest in a simple
and transparent way
we're just seeing it happening now and
you know and
and it's funny because it took me
you know warren buffett to hit my head
with
how easy capital markets are for me to
feel comfortable
shouting that more and more now i love
it
uh before we get back to crypto the last
thing i want to talk about in the kind
of traditional market is
spax it feels like everyone has a spec
uh and there are you know all these
transactions happening
you're seeing people speculate on
basically who the spac sponsor is you're
seeing
kind of great performance post
acquisitions or post deals
what are you guys seeing when it comes
to spax the trading of them
through client portfolios and kind of
just how that market is
uh is maturing so first of all specs of
2020 are icos of 2017.
so uh with the the institutionalized
icos into capital markets and that's
roughly what we're seeing so uh
you know they raised 60 billion dollars
of
dry powder to specs this year
um specs were traditionally you know
blank check companies who went
on to try and buy brick and mortar
companies
there were a couple of sponsor groups in
2018 and 19
which sort of led this change in
dynamics for
specs to invest in high growth companies
and over the past 12 months that entire
narrative just
took off and blew out of proportion and
i think
a lot of i have a lot of
a lot of the sort of ecosystem is
because
how it's built i think most people don't
really understand how specs work um
so what we have is great examples of
successful specs
whether it's uh draft skiing uh
which uh you know was an awesome you
know one of the
most successful specs earlier this year
uh whether it's things like virgin
galactic
which is a huge story uh
you know there were a lot of successful
specs over the past
12 18 months they all start in ten
dollars and a lot of them
sort of suddenly were at fifteen dollars
twenty dollars twenty five dollars
uh so it legit legitimized significantly
the entire sort of vehicle of specs
and i think it also attracted a lot of
very talented sponsor groups who said
hey they're great companies they're
great private companies
we saw a huge increase by the way as you
probably know
in private placements an increase in vc
there are more and more mature companies
um i think last time we talked we said
you know there's so many
mature internet companies who are
private right now raising a hundred
million dollars and staying private
now there are more and more companies
were generating 500 million dollars
revenues and are still staying private
and
spax is basically a tool of capital
markets
to sort of uh you know accelerate
them being public take all of these
private companies a lot
of them really great private companies
um and take them
into capital markets and i think by the
way this relates
very much to what we talked before about
the impact of retail investors
in the market so when you think about
taking
sort of higher risk profile higher
growth
uh profile companies at higher
valuations
through specs to the market than the
fact that retail investors are there
and participate in it it's a great
opportunity because
you can't get into ipos it's like
amazingly hard
for a retail investor to get allocated
to a successful ipo and here you
actually get to
trade the stock of the
the stack prior to the deal being done
right so a spec closes a deal with a
target
and until that you know month before
signing and closing uh you have this
trading which is interesting because
they're trading
on the basis of this pack is going to
buy this company i believe in this
company that a lot of shares are
changing hands
and retail investors are participating
in that as well and some of the spac
shares
uh some of them you know nikola was a
very big story this year
um so there's a couple of really big
retail stories coming from stacks this
year
in crypto what are the areas that you're
most interested in right you've
obviously been
uh a bitcoin uh holder and fan for a
long time but what other areas are you
paying attention to or interested in
um i i think you know i've always
i was always a big big fan of eth
i think moving east to staking
is super interesting having a
sort of let's call it uh eath risk-free
asset that generates five to ten percent
returns
i think that's super interesting
especially again look thinking about
macro
fiat right fiat is zero percent returns
you're buying now
bonds of berkshire hathaway with zero
percent interest rate
so uh i think having something as
big as eth which is uh you know i think
it's 42 billion dollar market cap now
um suddenly giving think about the size
of what they're giving right
five to ten percent a year to
their holders that's two to
five billion dollars of if
being distributed not to miners which is
complicated and requires you to buy
stuff
and to buy a hardware but just to the
holders
of if that that's a big paradigm shift
in crypto i think
um so very interesting to see what's
happening there we see its progress
i think because our interest in staking
we also started staking services in
etoro
so we started with cardano
it's also interesting to see like how
our customers
who have cardano on the platform were
banging the doors for hey
can we get staking can we get staking
and we had to like
they're they're shouting at us to give
them staking then we need to put like 10
engineers for half a year to figure that
out
because it's still an alpha but it was
fun like it's
because of that we've participated in a
lot of these early stages
of of of the staking protocols like
we're doing in eth
uh like we offered cardano uh we're
gonna
launch very soon uh tesos which has a
very different
view of staking which i think also is
interesting uh and i like what they're
doing at tesla's
um uh we're seeing tron uh i think we're
already giving staking so i think
staking is a big part of what's
happening
now in crypto and it forces also
us uh uh and the companies offering
crypto
to sort of connect more to to the rails
to the platforms to the blockchains
themselves
and obviously you can't talk about uh
crypto and what's going on without defy
right
what um on the staking product what are
you seeing in terms of the interest from
people is that something where
it's uh specific to a protocol uh or is
it kind of there's widespread interest
across all of the different
uh protocol groups that uh that they
really want this
i i think we've seen the most interest
coming from the cardano investors on
etoro
um i think eth is a bit earlier stage
i i you know it's also very complicated
because you need to lock it up
so it's going to still take a while
before
people i think expect that expect it
because it's sort of like uh
i don't know how to call it uh fork
schmork
uh with the whole uh ice age and you
know
locking up the eve for a year etc so
that's very
that's still complicated for most people
who are neat i think we haven't heard
that from them um so that's the
the loudest voice we've heard is from
cardano
i think a lot of the community there was
really interested to see
how they're moving from testnet to
mainnet
with our staking services got it and
on the d5 side are there specific things
that you guys are going to
try to build into the product or do
there that um
yeah this is a big divergence from the
stock market where everything's pretty
straightforward there's a whole bunch of
stuff going on
what are you thinking there so first of
all
we're following a lot of the action so
we like wherever we see action and
people uh
um uh where could you see crypto twitter
uh uh screaming and shouting you know
you need to to at least take a look so
i will be adding a couple of these
interesting
uh d5 protocols soon onto the etoro
platform
uh so far we were very focused on
blockchains but i think gradually
these defy tokens are somewhat
becoming similar to protocols just
without
the you know without the metals right so
if you think about it
all blockchains require computers and
mining and you know some hardware
and these d5 protocols just you know are
just sitting on top of
each mostly so it's like
progressing from hardware to software i
also you know i'm a very very good
believer
that code is going to change
uh legal uh sort of mumbo
jumbo so you know lawyers and
accountants eventually
so if you could do a transaction
uh in code rather than lawyer you know
200 page
legal agreements between three different
parties i'm a very big believer in the
future of d5
i think tokenization should happen first
before d fight can really happen
on large scale but i think what we've
seen this year in d5
is sort of a micro world or micro cosmos
of the entire banking industry
right we've seen loans we've seen flash
loans
we've seen interest yielding accounts
we've seen sort of mortgage-backed
securities
which are you know or or cdos which is
sort of what's happening uh with maker
so you've seen sort of
every single financial innovation that
you've seen in
wall street but you know that requires a
lot of
suits and lawyers and just being done
between financial institutions
i think you've seen all of that sort of
crystallized
into a you know developer chef
saying hey let's do something crazy here
and just
launching it and suddenly have a lot of
finance geeks
using it pumping it moving it
and it's super interesting i think
that's how finance is going to look 10
years from today i just think
uh right now it's still you know it's a
micro cosmos of
testing developing launching and using
it
all at the same time by really really
smart people
are you worried at all that um we may be
having a repeat
of the 99 like internet bubble and what
i mean by that
is uh if you go back to the you know mid
to late 90s all those ideas were
actually very valid and ended up being
highly successful companies it was just
the you know music streaming the grocery
delivery businesses like all of the ones
in the mid to late 90s ended up not
being the winner
it's almost like 10 years later is when
they actually got built and those were
the sustainable companies
does it feel a little bit like that is
happening in d5 right now where it's
like these are the right ideas and
i agree with you you know 20 years from
now we'll be like wow this is amazing
but maybe these iterations aren't going
to be the sustainable one
or do you feel like there are some that
uh can be the winners
you know that that are being built today
so
first of all all markets work on the
notion of bubbles and bursts
uh so this was my
thesis in my first degree was
uh basically a gaming theory that if you
actually put
agents and you build just a market of
bots
theory information all they know is what
everybody else is buying and selling and
you computerized it they
actually ran a simulation of it you get
to see and all the bot
knows is look what everybody's doing
decide whether are you buying today
the asset or are you selling today the
asset it looks like this
because at this point everybody says hey
everybody's making money
so what i should really do is buy now
and then down like this so that's like
in theory of markets that's how markets
behave
they go up for a long period of time
and then drop very sharply very fast
is defy specifically in a bubble right
now or does it justify the valuations of
the tokens
uh it's it's very it's very hard to say
because it's still very small right so
market cap of all of the d5 protocols
are still very small and in most of them
there are logical uh sort of revenue
generators
right so they're all basically financial
ins complex financial instruments
who sort of take money put money
in other smart contracts create some
type of
arbitrage or enabling others to create
some type of arbitrage
or take a market risk like uniswap so
take a
market maker risk right again it's
what's funny is if you look at
each of these protocols you can compare
them to something from you know you take
a goldman's accent there's a department
an entire department doing manually what
one smart contract in d5 is doing
so i think the answer is
prices uh can definitely still go down
um but there might be winners as well
in the group of d5 protocols we're
looking at today
but again we've seen what happened with
uh was it sushi who got slashed
sushi right yeah absolutely
what are you seeing when it comes to the
institutions in d5
you know the institutional services you
guys are building will that include d5
stuff in the future
and has there been interest from the
institutions in that
you know kind of subset of the crypto
market
i think uh so far we've seen more
institutions looking
into you know staking because they're
saying hey
here are yields how do we get our yields
on these protocols um from institutions
and defy i think it's a lot in the
research
so when we talk to financial
institutions
they're all excited they all have
blockchain teams right now
right so all the big banks and financial
institutions and institutions are
thinking about
sort of uh how do we tap into blockchain
how do we connect
so they're all hungry for information uh
they're hungry for potential sort of uh
product uh integrations or or testings
but i i think we're you know i don't
think we're gonna see institutional
demand for investing
in d5 protocols or in sort of
the def defy itself yet
yeah there's also a range of financial
institutions right
so 25 year old guy who made a million
dollars
in crypto console himself today in
financial institutions so
of course uh what's interesting to me
too i think is like if you go back and
you look
you know maybe in the 80s right into the
90s
a lot of the hedge funds that uh are
today the goliaths of the legacy
financial world
you know they started out with just a
couple million dollars and so you know
you kind of look around the room a
little bit and
uh one of the conversations i've had
with people is there are some
crypto funds that are uh you know hedge
fund in nature uh that will likely be
the citadels the renaissance the
you know uh name your favorite kind of
large hedge fund
uh of the future and part of that is
gonna be just because they're merely
trading an
asset in a market uh that those guys
aren't playing in yet and are unlikely
to
do anything in for some period of time
right it's kind of like when it when
those large hedge funds want to play
what do they go first they go to bitcoin
right and then it's like oh what's this
eth thing right and then maybe they'll
go to two or three others
to get to you know sushi swap uh is
gonna take a while
right and uh that feels like a big
opportunity for kind of the crypto
native audience
i think that exactly sort of uh you know
i was joking 25 it could be 35 or
45. that this group
uh of uh let's call them crypto hedge
funds for a second
of people who got rich in crypto and
and now said okay what now are we what
are we doing with our crypto right so
into at some point they said oh let's do
icos
uh then they said okay let's do uh
new protocols or you know this then that
then they said let's do uh d5 right so
it's a group of people
sitting on let's say a hundred billion
dollars these are not these are not
the what i call financial institutions
uh these are not hedge fund managers
these are
just the people who made the first
50 to 100 billion dollars of crypto in
the crypto space
um and they have a lot of crypto and and
they're looking
they're looking for arbitrage they're
looking for yield they're looking for
interesting projects
and that as long as crypto keeps on
growing
we're just going to see these guys
constantly be the early adapters
of the ecosystem yeah
absolutely those are definitely the
users on etoro
who we saw coming in on the toro
platform buying in
bitcoin in 2015
and by 2019 saying hey
i actually want to trade bitcoin to xrp
and bitcoin to
uh to to tron or you know i want to
actually use the exchange rather than
just
buy and hold an asset i i want to do
more with my crypto
i would be uh remiss if i didn't ask
what do you hold
whatever you want to say by the way
my entire holdings are public right so
etoro is a social network you can just
go to etoro.com i think it's slash
people slash uniasia
all right etoro and yonyasa you'll get
to see my entire portfolio
so um i am now about
uh i'd say 50 50 roughly stocks in
crypto
uh my biggest holdings by far in crypto
are uh bitcoin and eth so i'm a
70 percent uh sorry 70
bitcoin 30 eth roughly um
and then my stocks are extremely
diversified any
product i use and like i buy its company
so you know i do have some tron so i
bought some tron when i met i
i went with justin to meet warren
buffett so i have some tron
uh every every i think every uh
blockchain where i know the owners like
arthur from tezus i also at some point
said okay here
look here's my torah here's how how fast
you can buy tesla's
i think when i met him in a conference
so uh
i have a lot of i have a lot of the
smaller coins but let's say
it's about 10 of my portfolio um
and then stocks just anything i use
disney coca-cola
um jack daniels um
facebook google netflix amazon
uh so all the usual suspects any company
i use their products for a long period
of time and especially by the way if my
kids use their products
um i'll i'll i'll take a small location
my portfolio of that by the way when my
kids start using bitcoin
that's where the boom is going to happen
completely agree
uh i always ask everyone the same two
questions to wrap up but you've already
answered those questions so i have two
different ones for you
uh we'll start with the fun one first uh
what is your favorite hummus and this is
coming from people on twitter
what i don't know why they're asking you
but what is it
by the way i'm guessing it's howard
lindsen asking it um
it was not uh answer and then i'll tell
you who it was
so so unfortunately and you didn't say
anything about the fact that
since the last time you saw me i lost
like 15 kilos
um so uh fortunately unfortunately i'm
on a keto diet or fortunately i'm on a
keto diet
which means i meet a lot of i eat a lot
of meat
and no carbs and hummus unfortunately
is carbs so i i just eat a lot of trina
uh or tahini it's almost as good as
hummus
for uh for for anybody there in the us i
know really
took off but as good um and
uh i use the gamal one
all right the other question i have for
you is
uh it's much more fun i want to learn
which is you went to dinner with
warren buffett uh through this justin's
son
donation i think it happened whatever
uh what was the biggest takeaways that
you had or the lessons that you learned
talking to warren buffett for a
prolonged period of time
so what's personally amazing for me is
you know i've spent my entire life
on opening access to capital markets
because i believed
retail investors should uh be more
active
in the retail space but it was always i
had this
um you know fear of
shouting too loud and telling people
listen investing in stocks is
easy and it's easy to make money in the
markets because people always tell you
don't tell that to people you know be
you know put your disclaimers i think my
biggest aha moment sitting with warren
buffett is you know i read a lot of his
books
and he says by the way in his books
exactly what he says in person so i
highly recommend reading a lot of his
books
but he says listen if you look at the
stock markets
and you identify companies who you
believe
uh will just get stronger we have a moat
around them
right so you believe in their product
you look at their financials you unders
you can read their investor you know
relations page which people can
and it's really not that difficult to to
understand how to invest in capital
markets
he's just reading public materials and
if you can understand that and read that
and you can make the right decisions to
invest in companies you believe in
in companies that produce products that
you believe in
and you will generate double-digit
returns over a long period of time
and that's just you know and i think
that's what's happening
investors today millennials are suddenly
realizing i
i should use my money because when
you're compounding
um you know 20 returns
for 30 years you know it's it's it's a
it's a mind-blowing figure
uh and i i think that's the you know
he's been saying it in books i've been
reading it for years
but sitting with him and hearing it from
his mouth and like at some point i'm
like
i can't believe it he's that's what he's
been saying all the time that's
like the purpose of what we're doing in
etoro
uh and like until that point i was
afraid to just
shout out loud people should invest in
stocks people
should read financial reports uh in
uh if they make the right decisions just
which
isn't necessarily simple uh so you don't
need to sort of just
make decisions uh out of your wazoo but
if you actually
read and get educated you can generate
double digit returns
in the markets over a long period of
time and i asked him
do you think this is also correct now if
i would inve if i would give you the
next 50 years to invest
would you still be doing the same thing
you said that i would i would do it
better
wow it's so simple but people want to
make it harder than it really is
it's it's like everything it's yin and
yang right so
it's uh it's it's simple but but but
it's
complex um but again i think we're
seeing on etoro
we have now more than a thousand popular
investors who are being copied by others
the average uh um uh irr
return rates for our top investors are
30 to 40
on average for the past five years so
you know they they've been killing it by
the
combination of stocks in crypto and
that's why
suddenly this year the assets copying
popular investors on etoro
grew by uh i think it's uh five-fold so
suddenly people are looking at them and
saying hey this guy's
trading for seven years on etoro he has
a track record
a lot of them have this bump during
crypto winter so it's like
um and i think that's really the
awakening again of the millennial
investor
yeah it's awesome where can people go
find you on the internet or find more
about etoro
on etoro.com and when you're on
etoro.com after you register you can
just
write in yoni asia and you can see my
entire portfolio and holdings
and you can go and ask me why are you
holding
this stock or that stock or why aren't
you holding this stock or that crypto
and i'll behave i'll be happy to answer
all right and my parting question is
what are the updates you want to give us
on etoro itself in terms of
user metrics revenue future plans
whatever you want to share the floor is
yours
i have not come prepared to that
question uh but we've
had the best year of etoro ever so this
year is going to be better and bigger
than the crypto boom so
the you know corona rally
and the rise of a millennial investor
we've seen more than
four million registered users this year
we've seen revenues more than double
we've seen assets of our customers uh
almost
quadruple uh so like we've seen
mind-blowing figures
this year and i think we're seeing sort
of a glimpse to the future so people
new investors are flocking to the
markets
uh and it's very you know i'm so happy
to to see this this is what you know why
we've built etoro to to see this moment
in time
of the digital transformation happening
ladies and gentlemen that's yoni from
etoro thank you so much sir
thank you very much pomp always a
pleasure